字幕: Lais Ueti
校正: Kazunori Akashi
私は小さい頃 祖父に連れられて
よく山に行っていました
私の実家は 曽祖父の代から
林業と製材業を営んでいました
祖父は無線機の修理が得意でした
山の中で連絡を取り合うためです
そのため 私はその修理を見るのが
とても好きでした
なので 私の今の
エンジニアとしての側面に
影響を及ぼしているの
かもしれません
実を言うと 今日は
その祖父の命日でもあるんです
すごい偶然ですよね
きっとどこかで
見ていてくれるかもしれません
2016年 巨大な台風10号により
実家の屋根が吹き飛びました
皆さん ご存じのように
気候変動による災害の増加は
温室効果ガスが影響しています
温室効果ガスは
化石燃料の過剰な使用と
森林の急激な減少が
原因と言われています
私の実家は 日本有数の面積を誇る
ブナの森の北限近くに
位置しています
私の曽祖父が開拓した当時は
広いブナの原生林があり
そこで 鉄道の枕木や飛行機の
プロペラといった
交通インフラに関わるような木を
たくさん切り出していました
「切った木の数だけ山に戻す」
これは私の祖父たちが
山に刻んだ石碑です
曽祖父の言った言葉が書かれています
でも 私はこの曽祖父の
言葉の本当の意味が
つい最近まで分かりませんでした
私は現在 北海道に
100ヘクタールの森林を
親戚の分も含めて
保有しています
そのため 受け継いだ森林を
きちんと管理しないと
いけないという責任感から
実家に帰るたびに車で
森林を見に行くようにしています
しかしながら 短い休暇の中で
すべての森林を見るのは不可能です
100ヘクタールというと
ちょうど今
このデンパークが
７個分くらい入る広さだからです
そのため 帰りの飛行機の中で
地上を見るたびに 残念な気持ちになります
広さだけではなくて
クマも住んでいるからです
ちょうど長野県の根羽村にある
森林を見るバスツアーがあるため
そこに参加するようにしました
根羽村は安城市の
水源があるところです
根羽村に何度か足を運んでいくうちに
いくつかのことを学びました
森林を管理するためには
多くの人手がかかる一方で
その森林を管理するための
人手不足や 高齢化の影響により
十分に森林が管理できない
ということを知りました
適切に管理された森林は
森の中が明るくなります
そして下草が生えるため
森林の中が明るくなり
土砂災害などを防ぐ働きがあります
森林の価値は
木材だけではないのです
日本の３分の２は森林ですが
その森林の大半の面積に
スギやヒノキといった木が植えられています
スギやヒノキといった木は
植えてから20年くらいのところが
一番CO2を吸収しますが
一方で日本の大半の山林は
植えてから60年くらい経っても
いまだに切られていません
そのため 世代交代が進んでおらず
CO2の吸収はだんだん
少なくなってきています
私は現在 自動車部品メーカーに勤めており
安心安全に暮らせる社会を
実現しようとしています
しかしながら 自然災害の影響は
道路や橋といった
交通インフラにも影響を
及ぼしており
安全を脅かしています
自動車の製造や排出でも
CO2をたくさん排出するため
私はこの矛盾を断ち切りたいという
思いが強くなりました
ラッキーなことに私は山主でもあり
自動車部品のエンジニア
でもあります
自動車は安全性や快適性を
確保するために
センサーやモーターといった
部品をたくさん使用します
これらを森林管理に
応用することによって
森林がより効率的に管理できるのではないかと
考えるようになりました
このアイデアを実現するため
私は2018年
仲間と一緒に会社の
新事業コンテストに応募しました
森林を計測する試作機を作り
あちこちの森林で
計測するようにしました
森林の管理に困っている
自治体の人たちも 活動を進めていくにつれ
もっと広い面積を測りたい
もっと正確に測りたい といった
具体的なコメントを
してくれるようになりました
そこで私たちは
地上からだけではなく
宇宙からの画像も使って
分析をすることで
より森林の計測のニーズに
応えられるのではないかと考え
仲間と起業し 自治体から予算をもらい
開発を進めることにしました
私たちは 自動車や宇宙といった
興味のあることで
管理を効率化しようと進めています
森林を効率的に
管理できるようになれば
植林や伐採といったことも
より計画的に行えるように
なるかもしれません
もし全世界の森林を
正確に計測することができれば
大きな価値を森林から
生み出すことができると考えます
木がどれくらい光合成をして
CO2を吸収したのか
正確に分かるようになります
そうすることによって
温室効果ガスを少なくして
気候変動を抑えることも
可能になるかもしれませんし
適切に手入れされた森林は
土砂災害などを抑える働きがあります
「切った木の数だけ山に戻す」
私の曽祖父は 未来を豊かにするには
森林を適切に管理することによって
実現できると考えていたのだと
今は確信しています
私は興味のある宇宙や
仕事である自動車部品の技術を
掛け合わせることによって
気候変動という大きな課題を
解決しようとしています
皆さんはどういったところに
興味をお持ちですか
興味や好奇心を
掛け合わせることによって
気候変動を少しでも防ぐ糸口が
見つかるかもしれません
もし その糸口が見つかれば
行動してみてはいかがでしょうか
以上です